with pretty much no one there and we lit
loads of candles and it was like the
middle of the loads of candles
it's pretty much no one there and it was
the opening of Ray Liotta's newest movie
so we were able to talk to him and get
him for the music video
all right that's the last really other
thing I promise oh we got to leave right
along leave Ray alone rest in peace King
yeah
sorry I was also stuck on the fact that
Ed Sheeran
I don't know what I was expecting but he
just sounds like a default love Island
[__] participant I've never I still
I've never seen love Island
um here's the show well actually
obviously it's really a lot it's
obviously so it's any guy Richie movie
yeah okay
yeah Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
those people are supposed to be British
yeah
why are they not are they not ugly
enough they're not they're not pale
enough I imagine every person in Britain
is just desaturated and they're just all
like there's never any sun where did the
sun go yeah well no they all take the
short flights to like Ibiza in Spain
you're gonna play the new Hogwarts game
uh no because I don't care about Harry
Potter
are you
I probably hey I'll probably be dipping
in you're not really a gamer though no
but I can't I just want to dip in dude I
want to fly around
yeah is it like an open world
yeah what the hell is this
present
why what is this oh
more food for Hunter hey what is this
bit dude
I I want to go on record I did not ask
for any of this this is [__] up
oh a hunter or didn't order food okay
what a what a there's a lot of
unflattering bending over I don't put
the camera somewhere else Jesus Christ
he's like zooming in
oh oh
I see okay now this is the McDonald's I
like okay
there's actually food in there I'm not
gonna eat that but I will open this up
and is this a nice Coca-Cola over here
okay
if the camera's still in me don't be
[__] pissed
what what could you possibly be moving
the lens for that much wait wait here we
go
hi I'm hunter from meat Canyon
the 12-step program Navajo
kind of [__] accent are you doing
uh I love to stuff my big gullet with
Jack Daniels until I found the 12-step
programs true I can't feel my foot a lot
of the time because the diabetes
and then they're gonna in your
commercial they're just gonna be having
you draw pictures
with no ink in the pen yeah exactly
whenever I started the 12-step program
it was a lost cause
I actually I'm going to start taking
Chantix to help with my alcoholism yeah
just to see maybe if it doubles it works
oh my God that's crazy Ray was right
you smelled with that
maybe yeah you wanna help me out a
little bit yeah I guess why don't you
take a couple swings of that of this
yeah
nah I've never seen you drink regular
Coke drink just drink a little bit of
the regular Coke
how is it gonna it cannot hurt you that
bad
take a [__] drink of it dude what is
the problem because it's torturing you I
don't want to do it
God this [__] guy it's either you
take off those shoes and you show me
your feet
Hunter wants to see my feet so bad dude
you know when you're when you're gonna
where the [__] are you putting the coke
over there
I I got the thing off you ever bring it
back over here you see you see you see
what's going on here well this is a
whole bit I'm gonna go ahead and uh
I'm gonna do a little bit of it you know
there you go there you go
there you go move it over move it over
well take some drinks of it because it's
like what am I gonna put half a shot in
there just get it in there there you go
look at him ew yucky sugar I hate that
I don't like that anymore
do a
do it do an impression of what you think
I sound like actually
dude it's a huge cup God all I hear in
the back is just Jesus
[__] dude you know what there better be
some viewers who are just like man that
was like nothing yeah there will be
there will be two ounces of vodka video
yeah
the [__] Focus you had shaking that
it was crazy you've been talking oh boy
hey good what were you talking about
that was like a [__] oh man this is
your iPad right here
this is hey this is Daddy's iPad
that's good yeah I'm just gonna keep my
lap
just have to be nice and close
honestly try to do an impression on me
no I act like honestly you're seeing
you're going into like a weird no no I'm
his face you look I'm gonna cry no just
I'm think I'm thinking how of like
something you would say to me here's my
impression of you
yeah
okay
were you saying something stupid and
vulnerable
all right what the [__] were you saying
that was stupid and vulnerable dude I
don't know just anytime I'm vulnerable
with you you just go like what have you
ever been vulnerable with me oh okay
I'll be vulnerable with you right now
yeah tell me just a little something oh
what because you have to talk about your
troubled childhood dude have we not
heard that before
see see he does it he does it he does it
it's a good impression yeah
it was good
really oh now dad's dad started drinking
oh now I gotta go in my room
so you know what I hate about this
[__] chair is I look like a giant I'm
already big enough and like look at my
legs dude look at these thighs pressed
together you look cute man dude no
this is [__]
this is [__] up
walking on the set with McDonald's bags
dude really how long have you guys
planned this
um this is [__] how long did you
plan this bit
yeah it was actually ovie's idea well I
just respect the thought dude yeah I was
hysterical I'm like yeah do that you
want to be vulnerable with you I want to
please compliment right now I would like
I think Not only would I like that I
think your audience would like that you
know when you come off as a very dis
genuine person
I know
no I was actually saying to Lena last
night
that I love hanging out with you wow
because what I enjoy the most is you
consume so much art and I feel like
you're just a wonderful creative person
to be around because if anyone has ideas
you just have like this what feels like
an infinite well to be like oh man have
you looked at this or that kind of
reminds me of this and
I just feel like you're a creative
purist in that way you can always let
people
um you can always offer something that
enables people like achieve a vision and
I think that's a really awesome unique
quality man
thanks man yeah
is that you being
that just seems like a compliment to me
yeah I was saying I was going to pay you
a compliment Oh I thought that this is
you saying you're trying to be vote
I did say that yeah you wanted to be
vulnerable with you yeah like that
yeah okay
um
I think uh you're a very funny person
and it's just a compliment to me again
I'm talking be vulnerable I'm about to
okay I'm about to okay so because I
think you're a very funny person
sometimes I feel insecure around you
yeah and so I consciously make sure I'm
not trying to compete with you as a
person
um are you trying to say that you hold
back your performances whenever I'm on
this podcast
not even just on the podcast I think
sometimes when we record I don't uh
maybe sometimes I don't give it a
hundred percent why don't you give it
100 dude this is your show people are
showing up for you to be at 100 at all
times but I just have a lot of respect
for you
sometimes I think you know what I'm
gonna let Hunter Take the Wheel because
you know what dude that's very
vulnerable of you thank you for telling
me yeah
okay you want to try
no no
I don't think I will you know what
actually we can make sure yeah
we'll make sure you get very vulnerable
one second